[Aplausos]
olá eu sempre me encantei com o poder da
arte
esse poder que nos permite viver a vida
o mundo as relações sobre um outro ponto
de vista
esse poder de conectar pessoas de
conectar idéias
eu estou muito feliz de participar desse
primeiro td ex aqui em rio do sul
porque eu acredito que seja justamente
isso conectar pessoas conectar idéias
eu sinto me honrado com o convite e
confesso que bastante à vontade para
falar de arte aqui no palco da fundação
cultural da minha cidade
aos 12 anos de idade
eu comecei a fazer teatro e pouco tempo
depois eu já tinha certeza que o teatro
seria minha profissão muito cedo também
vieram os questionamentos
fazer teatro viver de teatro morando
numa pequena cidade do interior de um
pequeno estado longe dos grandes centros
onde a cultura se desenvolve
eu não desanimei ao contrário
passei a construir pontes que me levaram
ao contato de pessoas incríveis que se
dispuseram a me ajudar as melhores
lições que eu aprendi sobre cultura arte
teatro vieram da generosidade de mestres
que me diziam ser necessário dar para
receber e até hoje um esforço pra agir
assim
então eu percebi que era possível eu
poderia sim a partir da minha pequena
cidade desenvolver a minha arte
irradiava para qualquer lugar
montei espetáculos em si uma mochila com
bonecos e sair pelo mundo um pouco a pé
um pouco de bicicleta de trem de ônibus
e avião de navio
morando no motor home durante muitos
anos o meu roteiro de viagens era
definido poucas horas antes da partida
eu abrir um mapa sobre a mesa e dizia é
pra lá que eu vou
a única exigência que eu fazia pra mim
mesmo é que fosse um lugar onde eu nunca
tivesse estado antes arte e aventura
e dessa forma eu conheci platéias
maravilhosas
encontrei também outros artistas
talentosos de várias áreas que também
acreditavam ser necessário dar para
receber os espetáculos foram se
desenvolvendo a minha arte foi crescendo
alguns convites foram surgindo para
eventos festivais vieram alguns prêmios
reconhecimento e quando eu percebi eu já
tinha virado cidadão do mundo
a minha arte já estava sendo apreciada
por platéias na inglaterra na frança na
espanha em portugal na roménia na
hungria no vietnã no chile no uruguai na
colômbia entre outros países
aqui mesmo no brasil eu sempre tive o
maior orgulho de dizer que já estive
apresentando meus espetáculos em todas
as capitais do país além de muitas
outras cidades do interior e sempre com
a mesma alegria e gratidão fosse para
platéias com menos de dez pessoas fosse
para platéias com mais de 10 mil e de
repente eu me dei conta que aquele
prazer que eu sentia quando eu ia por
essas fontes
era o mesmo prazer que eu sentia quando
eu voltava eu sempre gostei de voltar
pra cá pra minha cidade mas algo não ia
bem algo lá no fundo me incomodava ao
sentido de levar a minha arte para
lugares tão distantes se as pessoas
daqui da minha região não pudessem ser
tocadas também apresentar um espetáculo
em hanoi em budapeste em santiago no rio
seria mesmo o mais importante do que
fazê lo aqui
a partir dessa inquietação
eu comecei a prestar mais atenção no
lado social do teatro que é um pouco
diferente de apenas montar um cenário
interpretar uma história receber os
aplausos do público e contabilizar os
ingressos
então em 2004 junto com alguns amigos
artistas e outros entusiastas da cultura
local
nós criamos uma associação uma
organização não governamental
mental alugamos um prédio na área
central da cidade local onde podíamos
desenvolver os nossos espetáculos
apresentá los para o público receber
outros artistas dar aulas
ali era possível sonhar durante cinco
anos
nós recebemos artistas de vários lugares
do mundo
apresentamos centenas de espetáculos
desenvolvemos eventos festivais ea
cidade civil tomada por arte
a gente conseguiu com as nossas acções
trazer envolver jovens inclusive muitos
jovens de comunidades periféricas que
tinham a oportunidade de uma atividade
social de desenvolver seus potenciais
artísticos de ter renda inclusive a
gente conseguiu também parceria com
grandes editoras distribuir milhares de
livros clássicos da literatura
literatura infantil para praticamente
todos os estudantes daqui e de cidades
vizinhas impactamos com as nossas ações
até as comunidades indígenas da região e
com tanta dedicação
acabamos recebendo alguns importantes
prêmios entre eles dois prêmios escola
viva do ministério da educação e um que
até hoje nos enche de orgulho e um
prémio do unicef que nos reconhecia como
a melhor ação sócio educativa
desenvolvida por uma ong de pequeno
porte em todo o sul do país
viramos referência mas como virar
referência não significa garantia de
nada ainda mais no campo das artes por
vários motivos nós tivemos que fechar as
portas e entregar o prédio mas aquela
associação de pessoas ela continuará
existindo e nós nos perguntávamos e
agora o que vai ser dessa ponte criada
entre a cidade ea arte
essa ponte criada entre a cidade e
artistas de tantos lugares
vocês já devem ter percebido que eu
adoro falar em pontes não é mesmo
então eu gostaria de pedir licença para
mudar um pouco o foco dessa conversa e
falar sobre elas
as pontes o dicionário traz várias
definições para a palavra ponte mas eu
gostaria de me ater duas delas primeiro
ponte substantivo feminino construção
que permite a travessia de cursos d'água
vales ou depressões
segundo pont figurativo tudo aquilo que
serve de ligação entre coisas ou pessoas
comunicação
eu só mais uma daquelas pessoas que acha
que a ponte é um símbolo impressionante
os europeus por exemplo criaram pontes e
imaginárias para ilustrar as suas notas
de euro cada nota uma ponte como símbolo
de união
cidades estados e até países têm pontes
como seus principais símbolos ea gente
não precisa ir longe para perceber isso
aqui mesmo onde estamos do outro lado da
rua bem à frente está a ponte dos arcos
um dos principais símbolos dessa cidade
na mesma rua a poucos metros para lá
está
estão outras duas pontes uma delas
chama-se ponte curt hering e foi a
primeira ponte construída na região
as pontes são lindas
sobretudo quando vistas de cima não é
mesmo mas embaixo delas
quem aqui já se atreveu a perceber o que
acontece embaixo de uma ponte
eu sempre ouvi dizer que é um lugar vou
ler ável marginal e eu gostaria de
mostrar para vocês o que acontece
embaixo de uma ponte
essa mesma ponte que a gente acabou de
ver a ponte curt hering
a primeira ponte da cidade eu gostaria
de pedir descrição e que vocês estejam
preparados pois as cenas podem ser
fortes
sabe aquele poder da arte que sempre me
encantou
aquele sobre o qual eu falava no início
dessa conversa é isso
a arte tem o poder de transformar
pessoas e pode também transformar
espaços ressignifica los como este que
de um espaço no mínimo suspeito
converteu se num dos mais badalados
pontos de encontro de pessoas felizes da
região
eu me atrevo a dizer que a única ponte
num mundo onde as pessoas são mais
felizes em baixo do que em cima e isso é
fácil de acontecer quando se encontra
grandes parceiros desde 2011 numa
parceria com a principal universidade da
região esse espaço denominado de espaço
cultural professor moisés boni vem sendo
administrado por aquela mesma ong criada
em 2004 amigos artistas que com seu
voluntariado já ajudaram a buscar
recursos ea ea realizar quase 300
atividades gratuitas e não foi só teatro
e essas atividades não foram só de todo
o brasil mas vieram também da américa do
sul da américa do norte da europa todos
embaixo de uma ponte e além do teatro
estiveram a de grandes músicos como por
exemplo arnaldo antunes escritores como
luis fernando verissimo
eles também já se encantaram com este
lugar o próprio luis fernando verissimo
um pouco depois de realizar ali um bate
papo literário seguido de um fantástico
show com a sua banda de jazz
ele escreveu em sua coluna nos
principais jornais do país
estávamos em baixo de uma ponte e
estávamos durante o evento no lugar mais
nobre da cidade
essa ponte já foi assunto de palestra na
dinamarca já virou notícia no jornal de
maior circulação no mundo o pipo aos
dele da china e mesmo assim muitas
pessoas daqui não a conhecem
é uma ponte democrática está de braços
abertos e recebe todos e todas sem
qualquer distinção e ainda dá uma
especial atenção à acessibilidade
esse ano por exemplo
todos os espetáculos que estão sendo
apresentados lá inclusive um está
começando aqui alguns minutos eles
contam com acessibilidade por exemplo
intérprete em libras para que os surdos
possam aproveitar também e em breve a
gente pretende oferecer áudio descrição
que é um recurso que transforma a imagem
em informação sonora para cegos e
pessoas de baixa visão através de fones
de ouvido
acreditamos que todos tenham o mesmo
direito ao acesso à cultura
se vocês ficaram curiosos e com vontade
de conhecer é muito fácil a ponte está
aqui no centro da cidade num local de
fácil acesso amplo estacionamento em um
ambiente é conhecido também como
encontro dos rios pois é ali que o rio
itajaí do sul do rio itajaí d'oeste se
encontram formando o rio itajaí-açu que
é um dos mais importantes rios de santa
catarina
o lugar também tem grande importância
histórica pois originalmente ali
encontrava-se um pátio de rituais
indígenas
com a chegada dos imigrantes dos
colonizadores
ali foi construído uma grande madeira
que aproveitava o próprio rio para
escoar parte da sua produção
mas o ciclo da madeira acabou eo local
acabou sendo ocupado por outras
indústrias de eletrônicos de alimentos
até que por fim foi incorporado pela
universidade local transformando se num
centro de eventos no centro tecnológico
incubadora de empresas e agora cada vez
mais com figurantes num importante pólo
cultural da região pois além do teatro
embaixo da ponte
ali também se encontra o museu da
madeira que é um lugar fantástico que
tem por exemplo uma serraria todo
original que funciona a partir da
energia de uma roda d'água tem uma casa
da memória indígena que presta uma justa
homenagem aos primeiros habitantes
dessas terras os índios xokleng e
capivaras tem muitas capivaras
é um lugar que vale a pena conhecer
eu diria que vale muito a pena ser
conhecido
dá pra perceber agora é tão bonito em
cima quanto embaixo não é mesmo
o teatro me permitiu isso ganhar o mundo
me permitiu também que o mundo estivesse
aqui na minha cidade o teatro me
permitiu literalmente construir pontes
que nos conectam com um mundo melhor
através da arte através do encontro
e eu não tenho a menor dúvida sobretudo
nos dias em que vivemos que é disso que
nós mais precisamos construir pontes
obrigado
[Aplausos]